Hello Freak bitches,
that happens just slightly because a lot
of people are in a cave in situation
when it comes to their lives,
they're literally buried under a series
of antiquated,
stale symbols that they're looking at
the universe through and they feel
trapped.
It's like their shoes are too tight and
if like a psychedelic or meditating too,
and I really mean that.
I'm not just saying that to say that
because I'm.
I really think meditation has a very
similar effect,
but any of these things,
they reset those symbols.
Structures in your brain and if you just
like if you're in a cave in and you get
an extra inch compared to like being
pressed against the wall,
that's a big fucking deal man.
So it's slightly percentage difference.
Change change is like,
oh thank God I'm 13 percent less
frightened than it was for my entire
life.
Have you ever heard Tony Robbins talk
about changing paths in life is you get
really,
really interesting analogy.
He talks about like you're going to cars
going the exactly saint or a boat or two
boats going exactly the same direction,
but one boat just takes a two degree
turn,
just two degrees here.
As they go further down the one boat
that took two degrees turn is going to
go wider and wider away from the
original path and that each decision
that you make,
that's a good decision.
Takes you closer even though it's just
like you're just steering your ship,
just dirt as you go out.
It's going to be a much different path,
a much different end than if you just
stayed on the original path.
That's incredible.
Different and psychedelics makes you go
right.
Turn Clyde.
Yep.
I mean at the the,
the currents.
Try to bring you back though.
Yes.
Well ego tries to eat bread in the
current.
Kind of bring it back to where you were
going,
so it's like got to take them a good.
Well,
I've always said get off that current
doing psychedelics.
It's like pressing the reset button for
your brain.
Like control all the.
Remember that,
that your your desktop reboots and
there's only one folder on the desktop
and that's that desktop says the folder
says my old bullshit and you have two
choices.
Either you just like create a completely
different desktop,
look at reality as a completely
different or open up my old bullshit and
fall back into these familiar patterns
because they're very comforting,
right?
You know,
in those moments after the psychedelic
experience are so important to grab and
hang onto because it gives you this
opportunity to make this new way of
thinking like a part of your habit.
Once you get in that habit,
whether it's fucking,
you know,
30 days or 60 days or 90 days,
like people say that once you like have
a pattern ingrained in how you behave
and think and do it just takes a
consistent approach to that pattern and
then it becomes like an like a part of
you like that's why people quit smoking.
Like get past 90 days and you'll be all
right.
Right?
Jews say when you have,
if you go to sit in the same feed three
times,
he's just keep sitting there.
That's your,
that's your two old time seed.
Wow,
that's smart.
I'd make sense.
It's like when you take a psychedelic,
it's like if your life is a polluted
city,
like what are those?
Polluted like Detroit,
Detroit.
Right.
And it's like the psychedelic all of a
sudden takes you in a helicopter outside
the pollution and so now you're seeing,
Oh God,
the air up here so fresh.
It's so nice down here.
But the thing is helicopter going to
land.
It's going to put you back out into your
city and that's where the job starts,
which is like,
Shit,
man,
how can I clean this fucking thing up?
And then that's,
that's like the.
That's when you start doing things like
exercising,
meditating,
or that's where you create just a very
simple intention in everything you do,
which is as much as possible.
I'm going to try to alleviate the
suffering of people around me as much as
I can.
You know,
not.
That might not be a lot,
it might just be call,
it might just be those.
So we got back from,
from this last UFC,
just a little bit of mushrooms was
enough that I saw a homeless guy and he
was looking for.
I was like,
I opened my wallet and I only have
twenties,
and I was like,
no,
fuck,
fuck it.
There you go.
That's what it does.
And those little moments,
man,
it shows you that you get those moments
present themselves to you all day,
fucking long.
But if you are stuck in selfishness,
you don't see it.
Yeah.
It's real simple little things,
but it's fun.
It's a very wonderful.
That kind of simple intention can really
deep pollute your,
your subjective city that you've been
sucking in shitty gas.
There was one title.
I saw it
that I was the only time I was like,
I've worked guide to somebody,
but it was Willie Hunter was on him and
he was shitting on following.
He was shitting on some like comic who
would become like a vine star,
you know,
so she was a shitty comment,
but it became like a.
and he was like,
I hate fine.
We're like,
fine man.
They're just for fun.
There's six seconds from videos.
He's like,
no,
I hate him.
Like,
what about a six second youtube video?
Watch that,
whatever.
He was just big,
shitty and really try to talk about it.
He couldn't stop that.
We started with the mushrooms and he was
like,
I'm a bad person.
Fine.
And he kept doing it and eventually I
was like,
listen,
you're right.
That was you being a bad person and I'm
so sorry.
But I was like,
it's okay because here's the deal from
now on,
you don't have to be that anymore.
You can just let that go and let people
talk.
And he's like,
yeah,
that's what it shows you,
like you can change,
but that thing you're talking about
where you realize,
shit,
I'm a bad person.
That is um,
there's,
I can't remember the name and Buddhism.
There's an actual name for that and it's
considered to be a very sweet moment
where you need that moment.
It's virtualized or where you need that
moment where you look at your life and
you feel this very specific kind of
sadness because you look at all the
times you could have been kinder all the
times.
You could have called that person back
all the times.
He could have made decisions that were
pushing your boat and the direction of a
better world and you didn't do it and
you should feel sad about that,
but you shouldn't spend your whole life
feeling sad about it.
You should just spend some time there
and look at it and think,
okay,
well that's gone.
The past has been devoured by time.
There's only this moment,
and so from this point forward,
as much as I can,
my decisions are going to be based on
reducing the suffering of my species,
and that means like if your trash is
when you have to let her keep going
forever.